please allow me to say a few words about
this conversation with Mark Zuckerberg
about social media and about what
troubles me in the world today and what
gives me hope
if this is not interesting to you I
understand please skip
I believe that at its best social media
puts a mirror to humanity and reveals
the full complexity of our world shining
a light on the dark aspects of human
nature and giving us hope a way out
through compassionate but tense chaos of
conversation that eventually can turn
into understanding friendship and even
love
but this is not simple our world is not
simple it is full of human suffering
I think about the hundreds of millions
of people who are starving and who live
in extreme poverty
the one million people who take their
own life every year the 20 million
people that attempt it and the many many
more Millions who suffer quietly in ways
that numbers can never know
I'm troubled by the cruelty and pain of
War
today my heart goes out to the people of
Ukraine
my grandfather spilled his blood on this
land
held the line as a machine gunner
against the Nazi invasion surviving
impossible odds
I am nothing without him his blood runs
in my blood
my words are useless here
I send my love it's all I have
I hope to travel to Russia and Ukraine
soon
I will speak to Citizens and leaders
including Vladimir Putin
as I've said in the past I don't care
about access fame money or power and I'm
afraid of nothing
but I am who I am and my goal in
conversation is to understand the human
being before me no matter who they are
no matter their position and I do
believe the line between good and evil
runs through the heart of every man
so this is it
this is our world
it is full of hate violence and
destruction
but it is also full of love
Beauty
and the insatiable desire to help each
other
the people who run the social networks
that show this world that show us to
ourselves have the greatest of
responsibilities
in a time of War pandemic atrocity we
turn to social networks to share real
human insights and experiences to
organize protests and celebrations to
learn and to challenge our understanding
of the world of our history and of our
future and above all to be reminded of
our common Humanity
when the social networks fail they have
the power to cause immense suffering
and when they succeed they have the
power to lessen that suffering
this is hard
it's a responsibility perhaps almost
unlike any other in history
this podcast conversation attempts to
understand the man and the company who
take this responsibility on where they
fail or they hope to succeed
Mark Zuckerberg's feet are often held to
the fire as they should be and this
actually gives me hope
the power of innovation and Engineering
coupled with the freedom of speech in
the form of its highest ideal I believe
can solve any problem in the world
but that's just it
both are necessary the engineer and the
critic
I believe that criticism is essential
but cynicism is not
and I worry that in our public discourse
cynicism too easily masquerades as
wisdom as truth becomes viral and takes
over and worse suffocates the dreams of
young minds who want to build solutions
to the problems of the world
we need to inspire those young minds at
least for me they give me hope
and one small way I'm trying to
contribute is to have honest
conversations like these that don't just
ride the viral wave of cynicism but seek
to understand the failures and successes
of the past the problems before us and
the possible solutions in this very
complicated world of ours
I'm sure I will fail often
and I count on the critic to point it
out when I do
but I ask for one thing and that is to
fuel the fire of optimism especially
those who dream to build Solutions
because without that we don't have a
chance
on this too fragile tiny planet of ours